welcome back to 8701
so we continue our discussion now of
electron and proton scattering
and we dive deep into this structure
using
deep inelastic scattering inelastic here
means that we are destroying the
structure of the proton in the
scattering process
so we have a way to look at the remnant
of the proton
and also of the scattered electron and
then
compare our theoretical expectation for
the cross-sections with the finding in
experiments
let me just talk about this in more
general terms
the energy of the probing electron or
the photon and the scattering process
allows us to look at the proton with
varying resolution
so at very low energies we basically see
a point like particle and then the
scattering process looks very much like
the scattering of an electron with a
mirror
if we increase the energy of the
electron we can see
that there's an extended charge
distribution in the proton
further increase and allows us to
resolve the fact that the proton is made
out of three quarks and if you increase
the energy further
we see a lot of new particles appearing
quarks and antiquarks and gluons
which make up the structure of the
proton
the picture here is i like this very
much i drew this myself some years ago
um is what i would like to you know
have you remember so in deep inelastic
scattering experiments we basically use
the photon scattered
radiated off the electron as a
magnifying glass for the proton
so we can look into the structure of the
proton here and we see the distribution
of the charged particles
in the proton only the electrically
charged particles we don't
have scattering between four direct
scattering between photons and lawns
so in measurements what we can do is we
can test a scattered electron
and we can look for the remnant of the
proton in our measurement and then we do
differential cross-section
measurements compare with our theory and
can infer
information about the structure of the
proton
to do this we have special kinematic
variables which
turn out to be very useful the most
important one is probably this x here
which is called the bjergen
scaling x of broken x which
you can think about so this is q square
as a momentum transfer of the photon
p is the momentum of the proton q is the
momentum transfer is q here
factor of two and what this is is
basically the fraction of the momentum
carried by the part on
here in the scattering process there's a
few other useful variables but i don't
want to go into any of the details here
so there's a number of very important
scattering experiments
um the first one i mentioned before is a
slag mit experiment
which led to the discovery that the
proton is made out of quarks
and the nobel prize in physics 1990 to
jerry friedman henry kendall
and taylor and what they did is they
basically had a beam
um at slack of electrons of 5 to 20 gev
and they scattered this beam of a
hydrogen target protons
and they use this spectrometer here in
order to then make a differential
measurement of the scattered electrons
so that's very cool um even higher
energies were available at hera
um the electron positron collider where
the energies of the electrons were in
the order of 30 gb
of the protons up to 3 830 gb
um and so what we find then in those
collisions of differential cross-section
measurement is shown here and it's a
very it's not an easy plot to read
so you see our structure function here
in the logarithmic plot
remember this is a log template here
and you see here q square the momentum
transfer of the photon so the energy
used in the scattering process
when we try to read this here we can
look at a fixed q square for example
and at a fixed q square you see that
um if you if you
probe if you're testing for a fixed
fraction of the patterns taking away
patons fraction of the partner's
momentum
of the proton you see that the lower the
fractions the more particles you see
so at a fixed energy you see
many many more particles the lower you
go in the fraction so there seem to be
like an
increase of particles um the lower the
fraction
is if you then check for
a fixed fraction let's say 0.4
um so it means that the pattern carries
forty percent of the protons
energy you see that it's almost flat as
a function of q
square so it seems like there's you know
forty percent
uh the number of particles you see at 40
percent of the momentum fraction is
constant with key square however
if you look at smaller energies oh sorry
smaller momentum fractions
you see that higher energies seem to
show even more particles at this
momentum fraction
and the ways to understand this is these
two
diagrams so the first one is this one
here
where you see a quark radiating clone
and so what you see is that you know the
deeper you look
you're able to then resolve this part
here
and so you see more quarks and gluons
which carry even smaller momentum
fraction than the initial quark here
you also see diagrams like this which is
called a blue one splitting with the
gluon splits in the clock and the cork
pair
and you start resolving those and those
also carry
lower momentum the evolution of our
of this pattern distribution function or
the the structure functions
can be calculated and described in the
so-called decline
equations and all you do here is
calculate the contributions from the
so-called
um work and glue and splitting so you
calculate those splitting functions as
higher order corrections
to a very simple quark model
and you find um that you can actually
very nicely describe those curves here
so you see this yellowing level here is
a qcd fit
which basically uses those splitting
functions as
input all right so we learned quite a
bit about
the proton already if we want to now
calculate a cross section of a proton
scattering with a proton
we are actually interested in the energy
distributions or the momentum
distributions of the particles in the
protons
and so we come back to how we use this
later but i want to introduce part-time
distribution functions which do exactly
that
they're defined as a probability to find
a part on in the proton that carries
energy between
x and x plus dx you can write them
[Music]
using the structure functions before but
they literally describe
this probability and so what you find
inside the protons are now the valence
clock
the down clock and the up quarks c
quarks and antiquarks
influence so you want to describe those
momentum
distributions or energy distributions of
those particles
there's a number of sum rules uh if you
integrate momentum fractions from zero
to one
one being the momentum of the proton if
you integrate them all together you have
to find one
because that is the momentum of the
proton to start with
if you integrate the down quarks in the
up quarks you find
one or two meaning that those are the
number of valence corks we have
available
if you integrate the distributions of
strange and anti-strange and charm and
anti-charm
you get zero well because there needs to
be the same number of
uh strange and anti-strange and charming
anti-strange
um and because of energy conservation
the sum needs to this sum so sums need
to be zero
and then we can look at those so what's
shown here is x
times the pattern distribution functions
the pdf
as a function of f and what you see here
for our valence quarks you see a
distribution which is kind of what you
expect
it almost peaks at 0.3 a third um and
has a distributions because there's
kinematics involved
and also um interactions because of the
interactions with
the clones and then you see
the the c quarks and antiquarks and you
see them
increasing in numbers quite
significantly as you go to small
fraction of the momentum carriage
it's exactly what we just discussed in
the previous plot already
an interesting way to look at this very
same distribution function is if you
plot them proportional to the momentum
fractions or the area proportional to
the momentum function and what you see
there
is that very significant part of the
momentum of the proton is carried by the
gluon
um so you see here again our valence
quarks our c
quarks and the gluons itself so that's
all i wanted to say on the structure of
the proton
we later in the lecture see how we can
use those pdfs those pattern
distribution functions in order to
calculate a cross section in portrait
protons
you